hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen grill rezept und
zwar ein vegetarisches grill rezept also
oftmals ist bei uns zumindest so wenn
wir grillen haben wir immer auch ein
vegetarier mit dabei dann fragt man sich
natürlich was kann ich selbst grillen
und wir haben jetzt mal eine alternative
zu einfachen gemüse schließen und zwar
geht es bei uns heute gemüse päckchen
mit zucchini und auberginen und
eingepackt ist ein grillkäse der
wirklich super lecker schmeckt bei uns
zu hause heißt er auch quietsch käse
wein weil es so quietsch beim der mann
fragt er immer leuten was wollt ihr euch
zum grill
ja genau ich sag meistens als schwarm
mitbringt
und dann finde sie cool alternativen
aber auch toll ist heißt eine
alternative wie viel zeit genial ist so
nicht nur wenigen genau wir essen bis
auch so bei uns gibt soviel
fleischsorten sag jetzt mal und dann
erst am grill knecht immer super perfekt
wobei ich denn jetzt heute musik
sozusagen nicht grillen werde sondern in
der planer zu bereiten werde
weil wir heute es nicht treffen können
ja und dazu gibt einen jockey und zwar
ist ein tomaten
aprikosen chutney und zwar ist es wie so
eine art grill beilage ein stick kann
man das essen als sauce und es passt
sieht auch super vom geschmack her zu
dem käse dazu das ist so leicht süßlich
und säuerlich und passt aber auch ganz
gut so fleischgericht genau war noch
ganz gut wenn wir noch vegetarisch
ernährt toll finde ist grüner spargel
grillen richtig haben nachgang cent das
ist wirklich das so sagt baudisch und
einfach er genau also echt tolle
grillrezepte jedenfalls starten jetzt
gleich und ich werde es zuerst einmal
ist kaffee zubereiten weil man es
vorbereiten muss und dann sage ich euch
die grill päckchen für das tomaten
chutney brauche ich 700 automaten bei
aprikosen zwei esslöffel olivenöl etwas
ins netz 20 gramm drei schalotten
jeweils einen teelöffel koriander samen
und sind könner eine chili 100 gramm
braunem zucker 100 milliliter apfelessig
ein paar zweige rosmarin und salz und
pfeffer zuerst nimmt ihr jetzt die
tomaten und das geht am besten mit einem
toten mutter und ich schneide ich jetzt
in scheiben und die werden jetzt vorher
nämlich so ein bisschen gegrillt in der
pfanne damit einfach der geschmack etwas
intensiver ist dort in strom schneidet
jetzt gerade noch hier raus
dadurch den topf bereits erhebt und da
gebe ich jetzt einen esslöffel olivenöl
rein und da wäre es die tomaten von
beiden seiten scharf angebraten könnte
auch eine grillzange zum beispiel immer
wenn sie gekippt
während die zweite portion der tomaten
hier noch vor dem brett kann ich jetzt
schon mal die zwiebeln fein hacken und
auch dem ingwer schälen und fein hacken
die tomaten sind jetzt raus ist auch die
dunklen stellen im topf mit einem tuch
bisschen weggenommen
jetzt könnte den gleichen topf nehmen da
das restliche öl reingeben und da werde
ich jetzt die zwiebel und den ingwer so
ein bisschen antraten chili habe ich
auch schon fein gewürfelt und stehen
beratungen an
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die tomaten nehmen dies ein
bisschen 'schon abgekühlten und wird den
würfel schneiden und genauso wie
aprikose
gleiche tomaten und aprikosen wirklich
hier wiederzugeben genau gekippte so ein
bisschen reduzieren
das land langsam nur köpfe und rechts
ganze auch würzen
jetzt kommt erstmal zucker mit reinem
zucker hebt natürlich den tomaten
geschmack und dann bis jetzt einfach
selber abstimmen wie viel zucker ihr
nehmen wollt ich gebe es auch erstmal
nur die hälfte das so und kann dann
einfach später mal probieren mit dem
essig lösche ich das ganze ab und gibt
auch gleich ein paar stängel das
mariazeller zweiges und die koriander
sammeln und die sendung kerner werde ich
jetzt erstmal in einer gewissen
zerkleinern
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel in
moerser nehmen
ab
es kommen da auch die gewürze mit rein
und da könnt ihr natürlich individuell
abstimmen welche gewürze ihr nehmt ob er
überhaupt koriander und senfkörner neben
wollt oder wir ganz andere gewürze und
kräuter nehmen jetzt noch ordentlich mit
salz und pfeffer würzen und dann lasse
ich das chutney für etwa zehn minuten
einkochen und kann schon mal die
zugfahrten vorbereiten
für diese carpet
das schatten ist jetzt eingekocht ich
werde jetzt hier noch die rosmarinzweige
rausnehmen
die kann man nicht so nicht mitessen
damit er mit schönes aroma an das
chutney abgegeben
und hier im kopf habe ich schon mal vier
einmachgläser abgekocht und zwar so etwa
fünf bis zehn minuten dann sind sie
steril und können jetzt dieses schatten
nämlich auch richtig gut aufheben und
dann könnte dem aufbewahren
am besten kurz abtropfen lassen
und jetzt füllt ihr das chutney noch
kochend heiß da rein und last am besten
so wenig platz wie möglich das heißt
fast bis unter den rand füllen und dann
kann sie kann man eben am längsten
aufhören
jetzt kann ich es kurz zum abkühlen weg
stelle und sage ich davor noch mal kurz
geführt hatten für die käse päckchen an
zutaten brauche ich eine verschiedene 2
nie etwas thymian und hier habe ich noch
einen grill und pfanne käse und zwar ist
es ein käse aus kuhmilch der aber eben
richtig schön fest und kompakt ist man
kann den super auf einem grill
zubereiten oder eben auch in der pfanne
jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal die
zucchini und die aubergine nehmen und
die jetzt in feine scheiben hobeln
dafür nehme ich jetzt da hinten das
stück weg und auch hier vorne
und jetzt nehmen die ihr entweder einen
sparschäler um die scheiben abzuholen
oder ihnen einfach so einen hoch
beim anfangs stück könnte es übrigens zu
machen dass er darin sparschäler nimmt
dann könnte das anfangs stück der
aubergine nämlich auch benutzen und hier
einfach ein bisschen von der schale
wegnehmen lässt sich gleich besser
rollen
jetzt kommen die zucchini und auberginen
scheiben in salzwasser und zwar ist es
jetzt schon bereits aus der box und da
kommt jetzt rein wir müssen einfach
eintritt zwei minuten gekocht werden
damit sie einfach etwas langsamer werden
und die auberginen verlieren so übrigens
auch ihre bitterstoffe
sie schreiben hier heraus lassen sie
auch etwas küchenpapier abtropfen
jetzt nämlich dem käse und schneidet ihr
den sechs teile da müsst ihr natürlich
einfach mal gucken wie breit eure
zucchini und auberginen scheiben sind
und dementsprechend groß oder klein
könnt ihr den käse daneben schneiden
nehme ich mir jeweils eine scheibe und
stark minister käsereien dann doch ein
bisschen thymian für den geschmack
und könnte das so einwickeln
und dann da unten ganz einfach mit einem
zahnstocher feststecken
wir sind alle fix und fertig und ich
werde jetzt noch mit etwas olivenöl
bepinseln
es hat einfach mal ein bisschen schwach
und die zweite seite bestreicht hier
gleich in der pfanne
die panne ist jetzt schon mal heißt also
wie gesagt könnte die jetzt so auf den
grill legen oder in der pfanne
zubereitet und ich mache für zoll in der
pfanne moral verdächtige schon jetzt mit
der olivenöl seite nach unten
da kann ich eben hier gleich noch mal
drauf streichen
und so werden sie jetzt bei mittlerer
hitze von jeder seite etwas 56 minuten
angebraten
also defekt sind jetzt fertig und am
besten stg auch wirklich noch ganz heiss
für teilst du bekommst jetzt eins auf
der pfanne hat nur den käse ist ja kein
schau im [ __ ] hat sich jetzt noch
gewünscht dass es eben noch nur käse
anbraten und deswegen berate ich jetzt
gleich noch den mit chili wolf stören
die fans gerne dem chili weil es am
liebsten käsemarkt war ich weiß wer
kriegt ja der krieg nämlich der
quietscht im hinterkopf ist es auch
richtig cool und den auch morgen
deswegen wenn wir am ehesten ist den
bewegen auch vergangen genau kann ich
jetzt schon heiß
das macht ja nix kanada das sharkoon hat
einen namen gemacht das große hobby
kommt gewonnen
gibt jahren aufgaben wurde wie gesagt
auch vegetarische machen also dass
vegetarisch machen möchte und ich
probiere jetzt mal ja sie hat den zahn
schon raus und kann mir gut vorstellen
dass es auch kalt schmeckt aber heiß
schmeckt natürlich am besten
und ich kann jetzt schon mal hier den
käse separat anbieten also lecker
schmeckt zucchini und deswegen lässt
sich nicht wirklich also echt cool als
schattenriss gar nicht probiert das
manchmal problematisch so richtig gut
mit rosen und schaffe es erinnert ein
bisschen süßlich
durch diese schärfe und durch die würze
das ist echt ganz gut zu grillgerichten
also wird auch kurze fleischgerichten
passt also ich mach dich schaffen ja auf
jeden fall mit macht es scheint mir auf
jeden fall mit weil wenn nicht macht
dann schmeckt der käse und das chutney
und die zucchini oder auberginen ihm ein
stück wird positiv oder negativ positiv
zu buche
hasko dazu und dann
hat man schon das perfekte rezept der
fall wäre dieses rezept ist auch nach
machen wollen dann geht einfach aus
berlin ist block der jeder stets noch
mal ganz genau für euch und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen oder
wir sehen uns nächste mal
und du kannst nächstes mal einfach
glücklich